to show you how stupid this whole thing
is we played it a couple times during
the campaign when Joe Biden repeatedly
said but there's one moment where he
really drove it home repeatedly said
that it should not be the sex on your
birth certificate that sends you to a
male or female prison it should be what
sex you identify as now we know that
biological men are going to women's
prisons and raping and beating women
apparently this is the feminist position
now Merrick Garland was asked about just
that
when it comes to federal prisons are you
whether 1200 prisoners are requesting to
be sent from a male prison to a female
prison
I'm not no okay
uh what is our policy when it comes to
allowing a male prisoner to
be transitioned into a female prison
I I think if you're generally asking the
question of how um uh trans people are
dealt with in the Bureau of Prisons my
understanding
um is that these are determinations
about
um uh where they're placed or where
people are placed in general have to do
with individualized determinations
regarding the security of that
individual and the management of the
prison these are done on a case-by-case
basis that's my understanding are you
aware of any policy guidelines that they
use to make that determination I think
there is a policy guideline along the
lines that I just said that that day I
would I would like for the Bureau of
Prisons to send it to us are you
concerned that if a biological male is
sent to a female prison that could be a
risk to female prisoners I think every
uh person in prison has to be dealt with
with dignity and respect
well every person except the chicks in
the women's prison apparently uh for the
record I watched every episode of Orange
Is the New Black and frankly a women's
prison seems far scarier to me than a
Men's prison Libby
surprised I guess not surprised like
what I
um are out of prison but who imprison
with men I've talked to women who are
currently serving time alongside men in
the women's prisons and these are real
problems um unfortunately when you bring
up something like this why are there men
in women's prisons no one really cares
because these women are already at the
bottom of society they're women they are
criminals they in many cases are poor
they were already in many cases subject
to domestic abuse and violence
um which led in a lot of cases to their
arriving in prison in the first place so
one woman that I talked to who is
currently serving time in the central
California Women's Correctional Facility
has told me about when men come into
prisons there they self ID in they are
fully intact uh they have not cut off
their hot dogs everything's still
perfectly functioning and the prisons
will
um they will vacate an eight woman cell
in order to accommodate one man who will
then be housed in that cell they are
given roommates
um who are women and they end up in many
cases in sexual relationships with these
women it's not just abuse and rape but
it's also the entirely changing Dynamic
that happens when a man a man enters a
woman's face and there's rivalries and
things like this
um this woman was also telling me about
how a trans inmate
impregnated a woman at the prison if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell